previously on the walking dead what's
his name
Kenny come on don't make the children
wait shut excuse for you what is it Lee
yeah yeah huh why didn't the hell didn't
you hear the bell
Oh dinnertime
hey hey good Marty how's it going didn't
you hear the bell oh [ __ ] we just got
caught dinnertime
oh my god why is the doors there's so
much blood in there look we have food
here but Danny and I still got to do a
lot of hunting to keep everyone fed just
in it dress it back there mama doesn't
like us to make a mess in the house so
you see nothin to worry about
ma giving you free food man be grateful
I don't know about this bro
what what was that what did I person
come from what in the hell was that
did you see them
excuse me miss we had to block the back
door after Walker got upstairs don't
worry that was a while ago and I ain't
been back inside since everybody sit
down now go get the meal Oh where's 10-8
horse we're smart
yeah Marc now don't you worry about him
I've already brought some food oh you
just let him rest all right
mind if I wash my hands first bathrooms
right outside in the hall and be
to get under your nails you've been
mucking around on the dirt off all right
ma'am
I got a bad feeling about this bras re
most appealing cow spots that's good for
you man
all right I'm not actually here to wash
my hands
I'm here to snoop around Sherlock pits
what is gonna Lucien might is this
girl's perhaps uh-huh all right let me
get up
sneaky pits initiating mark seriously
mark I'm concerned from my mane
what is this little thing but it's dead
whoa [ __ ] not suspicious or anything Lee
you go mark I mean
ah it's a closet door what is these two
what is that cord going and I'm [ __ ]
now what is this stuff looks like a
bunch of medical waste in here would be
to say li na dairy farmers need with
this kind of stuff
alright let me get back there's
something fishy going on breath let's
check on mark mark where the hell was
mark look Brenda said he was up here
resting what is it there's something
fishy going here that painting feels
like there's a storm coming
I don't have a lot of time Lee we gotta
investigate god damn it it's not going
well what about in here
bye bye we got a fun we gotta find you
I'm missing something I'm missing
something ain't I
maybe I should go down and ask them
about what the [ __ ] he is well what what
okay this is freaking me out mark
mark Martine who they need so much
morphine for what is that cord going
okay this is [ __ ] disturbing what in
the hell let's put these together why Oh
what is that cold going it's going
through that wall there's a secret room
inside of that behind this shelf
it's mother
oh my god what is going on it head I
don't like this mark
my what happened me don't eat it
are you get the gun Clemmy
don't eat that
oh yes Lee Jesus man
did you find something oh sit your ass
down Lee this lady has made you a meal
yeah Lee what's gotten into a turducken
they could use some goddamn manners mark
is upstairs with his [ __ ] legs cut
off
you're eating him you're scaring the
kids Lee Lee what the hell is wrong with
why did you listen to me don't indulge
him Lily it's always something with this
guy I was eating that we need to get the
kids everyone out of here we need to go
now everything could have turned out
okay for you folks he would have died
anyway we gotta think about living that
oh babe honey holy [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
pharmacist it's how I was raised and how
I raised my bones now holy [ __ ] there's
roaming around but do nothing but eat
people and for what to continue to rock
till they eat some more we think we can
put that neat to better
yeah you [ __ ] ahead Lee that's not a
very nice thing to imply no but eating
people's legs isn't nice either we go
after folks who were gonna die anyways
one way or another
like y'all Clementine
run nobody's going anywhere we got news
for y'all right here everything is gonna
be everyone everything will be okay
hey don't worry Clemmy don't you dad
caveat Kenya hey you [ __ ] [ __ ] well
tear you apart that's mark son of a
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] disturbing maybe he's a
walking don't they get wet
oh thank god Clem is here it was a
person they tried to make us eat a
person yep
you didn't do it no the rest of us did
god damn it
if you hadn't dragged your feet my dad
now's not the time
you okay Clementine more clammy
they didn't hurt you today Oh son of a
[ __ ] psychos have my family we're stuck
in a damn meat locker
oh they got duck aged Oh daddy it's
gonna die okay I'm gonna find us a way
out of here
yeah all righty they don't give up we're
gonna find a way out of here
can I help sure yes you can promise
mightier than one spool screws are loose
panels anything we can pry a way to open
a passage out of here okay good guy a
tiny hole behind these ballots no they
couldn't
no such luck
nope way to evening chills are pretty
sturdy we could climb up but there's no
way out through the ceiling well what
about the vent
oh I'll break that down Georgia dad you
can't go Wow I know your heart is he
gonna zap I know come on dad Oh God
he stopped breathing I think he's had a
heart attack [ __ ] he did he's not dead
well I don't know what to do if he's
dead Oh
oh this is bad
[Music]
minutes we're gonna be stuck in a locked
room with six foot four 300-pound
seriously pissed off dead guy [ __ ] you
we can bring it back late morning later
but right now we'd have to keep him from
coming back too exciting why do I know
he's not dead he can't kill us I'm sorry
I know you all hate Larry I hate him
care to get that monster off achacha and
Larry's twice his size it's him or us
look Kenny back at the drugstore when we
all thought duck was Ben I gave him the
benefit of the doubt maybe we should do
the same now that was different
duck wasn't bitten but come on we know
this guy's not gonna make it remember
what Ben said got to destroy the brain I
didn't I can't I can't do that hit me in
the middle line you gotta have my back
this time god damn it Lee I need you
please help me oh [ __ ] I got a chill
what is wrong I don't want to choose
I couldn't get laid Kenny's my friend I
could get laid Kenny's my friend I know
oh no I'm sorry
I don't me okay me Louise said he wasn't
dead
I'm sorry hey hey one was dead
clementine but what if he wasn't he was
I promise I'm sorry Connie
it's alright Clanny but you gotta be
strong right now I need you to be strong
think about something else something
hopeful like what yeah walkie talkie
talkie those pretend talks with your mom
and dad don't those make you feel better
sometimes we're gonna get out right you
found a way out I think through this
vent
Sana's he's gonna be he was gonna get
zombified don't don't look at me like
that
okay I feel like an [ __ ] or I do
maybe bigger goddamn egg through I don't
know Lee seems like a long shot does
your conditioner come on I think I could
take it off if I had something to remove
the screws that game I have my
multi-tool of course they took it [ __ ]
Johnny something else we could use I've
got a rock rock won't help do you have a
coin I think Gloria has a coin actually
you mention it if you remember to mark
oh this is terrible he does have a coin
I remember this
oh just need told you to get the [ __ ]
away all right she bites Lily and he got
a new head I'm sorry
don't talk to me Lee don't [ __ ] talk
to me I regret this so much Larry would
a water
[ __ ] you you think he wanted this of
course not you don't know what he wanted
you never knew him you never gave him a
tree maybe not maybe maybe I should have
tried hard but I know he had you that
doesn't make sense
he wants you to get out of here
I think I may have found a way out of
here but I need something to remove the
screws on the air-conditioner if you had
something I could use as a screwdriver
he has a kind no what about him
I know this is a terrible time for it
back at the motor Ian's Larry Larry
mentioned something about keeping coins
in his pockets in other words my
father's more useful to you dead than
alive if he was very much had the key to
getting us out of here do you think he'd
keep it to himself what do you want my
blessing to loot his corpse yeah
permission do what you have to do oh god
damn it I'm an [ __ ] I'm god damn it
oh come on that is terrible any idea
which pocket II why do they make me do
that I feel like such it god [ __ ]
poacher
well I don't think this is gonna end
well that's his deck that's disgusting
my mother's don't worry about taking it
here we go two quarters and a dime
that's perfect
thank you eyes man hey salt the man all
right let's get this going and remove
these screws and get this unit off
alright let me investigate
all right that goes why I got it yeah
one more should do it
that's pretty that was pretty easy one
do
got it
there's no way out me this ma probably
lead right into that back room it's too
small for us to fit through I can do it
no climbing you can't no no it's out of
the question
you don't have today enough to do this
right I know I just want to go home this
will help us get back home
okay Jake this guy that's freaking girl
ever timing you're gonna be fine
what do I do when I get out see if you
can get to the other side of that door
and open it
i clammy I trust you be safe
it's making a lot of noise I don't like
this
what's going on Clemmy are you ok good
I'm a [ __ ] real let me gotta go leave
me alone
wait I can see him it's not safe for me
for God's sake Lee didn't even get to
say goodbye it's true get in here
and stay here take care of Lily okay I
will
I press gonna end up saying that was
thousand that was so much I don't even
know what to do anyway lack of fair to
the enjoin sky from a birthday Bobby
read thousand get our battery
yeah yeah shaking